crypto asset manager grecale is in talks
with firms including JP Morgan and
Goldman Sachs to potentially play a key
role in its proposed Bitcoin ETF that's
according to a Bloomberg report that
says the banks are being considered to
be authorized participants firms that
have the power to create and redeem
shares of the fund it would provide
liquidity and ensure that the ETF share
price tracks with the funds underlying
assets Black Rock previously named JP
Morgan Securities to provide that
service for its proposed Bitcoin ETF JP
Morgan CEO Jamie Diamond of course told
Congress last month that he always been
deeply opposed to crypto and Bitcoin and
if he were uh the government he'd close
it down well Traders are on alert as we
get closer to the sec's January 10th
deadline to approve spot Bitcoin ETFs
joining us now with more on the various
regulatory outcomes that could impact
crypto trades Anthony Pompano founder
and partner at pomp investment Anthony
good to see you this morning absolutely
thanks for having me so I have to just
dial back I go back to when the Spy was
listed 30 plus years ago I covered it
then the Uso the oil ETF the gold trust
in 04 and
06 there was never anything like this
anticipation we didn't we don't talk
about ETF launches and who the
authorized participants are this is
bureaucratic back office stuff it's just
how the how the trades function so all
of which is to say the degree of
anticipation of this and how it's made
its way into the market is Extreme how
is it not just a anticlimax when it
happens Wall Street is getting invited
in anticipation of The Greatest Show on
Earth right Bitcoin has been the best
performing asset for the last 15 years
and wall Street's basically in boxed out
of it they haven't had access to this
asset and so I think that s you're
seeing that pent up um excitement one
thing that I do caution these Wall
Street investors is you can't trade this
like other assets we saw just yesterday
about a billion dollars of open interest
got wiped out the guys who are at
reflexivity research did a fantastic job
outlining saying you know this asset in
202 uh one went up almost 800% from uh
before the pandemic started to the kind
of the top of the market yeah during
that time was 5 30% draw Downs if you're
going to try to get levered long and
think that hey ETF gets proven this
thing just goes to the moon you're
likely to get shaken out or get L that
is really good advice just Beware of the
volatility that I mean this thing is is
on a risk return basis it's the by far
the most attractive asset in all the
financial markets but it comes with tons
and tons of volatility and so if you go
back to 2017 it was $1,000 we're 45x
since 2017 but along the way we've had
two 80% draw Downs a pleth I can't even
count how many you know 30 plus perc
draw downs and so Wall Street is saying
hey the etf's coming here we go now I do
think over a long period of time
bitcoin's price is going to continue to
go up we're going to have a persistent
bid from all these ETFs another thing
people aren't talking about everyone's
talking about the primary uh fund flows
so retail or institutions buying this
ETF but actually what we're starting to
see now is other publicly listed funds
or ETFs are changing their perspectives
to say that they can put up to 15% of
their AUM in the Bitcoin ETF so if you
have the best performing asset and you
got an ETF that's lagging why would you
not put Bitcoin in your ETF but all of
this really really formalizes the
greater full aspect of why Bitcoin
should go up right it's just there's
more there are more people who are going
to get in there and Buy and they have a
new easy way to do it meanwhile it it's
easier to own Bitcoin directly than it
was to own a barrel of oil or gold bar
or Futures Contract when those things
were introduced it didn't change the
overall price curve I think there's two
points you're making first is when you
buy the CTF you were not buying Bitcoin
you were buying exposure to bitcoin but
if you want to actually own Bitcoin take
self- custody you should definitely go
do that not do it through the ETF the
second thing though is this kind of
Greater fool Theory one thing I always
say to people is what is the most
valuable commodity in the world in my
opinion it's computing power Bitcoin is
the strongest computer network in the
world and so when you're buying Bitcoin
you're buying an asset that is backed by
the strongest commodity in the world so
when you start to think of it from that
perspective yes it is internet native
yes it is for this kind of digital
generation but those people don't look
at oil or gold or anything else as the
most valuable commodity they look at
computing power and that's why Bitcoin
is so attractive to them can I ask a
very simple question if I own Bitcoin
through an ETF do I have greater
protection of my ownership of that
Bitcoin interest than I did through some
of the exchanges where I've heard some
nasty stories so it you definitely have
the exposure and obviously it's a
regulated entity uh you have the ETF
structure all the things that I think
Wall Street really enjoys about the
protections of those regulated regulated
funds uh what you don't have though is
direct exposure and ownership of Bitcoin
itself so one of the beauties of Bitcoin
is similar to cash you can go to the ATM
you can take the cash out of the machine
with Bitcoin you can actually take self
custody you can own it you don't have to
rely on any counterpart you don't have
to rely on an exchange you don't have to
on an ETF uh provider Etc and so people
have to ask themselves what is my
comfort level am I comfortable taking
self- custody or do I just want the
financial exposure and I don't want to
deal with that and I think that that's
where you're going to see a lot of
people who've been sitting on the
sidelines institutions they can't take
self- custody they need the ETF to be
able to actually allocate to the asset
hey Anthony the coindesk the block a lot
of different places are reporting on
this Matrix Port report um from an
analyst who says that the SEC is going
to say forget it they're going to reject
the ETF the spot Bitcoin ETF proposal I
know you think that's a real long shot
what would happen if if they actually
did do that if the SEC said no if they
approve it I think that there will be a
lot of short-term volatility and we'll
kind of get right back on track whether
it goes up or down after the approval if
they reject it I think the same thing
would happen there would be a lot of
kind of short-term volatility and we get
right back on track the beauty is with
Bitcoin if we go back we we saw
something like this China had over 60%
of all mining inside of their borders
they completely banned Mining and kicked
them all out 50% of the rate went
offline by the end of that year may of
2021 is what to happen by the end of
2021 mining hash rate was back to an
all-time high and so this thing is just
resilient it's antifragile and it
continues to just do what it was
designed to do that's true although the
risk reward you know that the the
returns based per unit of volatility you
site it really depends on the starting
point right I mean two and a half years
ago you were here you were saying
$100,000 really soon we're going to get
there on bitcoin and it's been nothing
through this inflationary Spike and a
Fed tightening
I I always say look at $8,000 right I
thought I was going to 100 it only went
to 70 I was off I was off by a little
bit right but but in terms of I I think
these directional moves again it goes
back to there is a lot of volatility
here and I do think that the volatility
will dampen as obviously ETFs and kind
of more persistent sticky holders come
into the market but remember we not
aren't just talking about an ETF either
we also have the having that's coming up
at the beginning of Q2 and we've got to
return back to loose monetary policy and
so I think that we are going to see a
pretty Ser significant move in Bitcoin
just don't expect it to go from 45,00 to
a million tomorrow right gotcha all
right well we'll manage our expectations
accordingly thank you Anthony appreciate
it absolutely